why don't we start though with your big
speech today and the big announcement
contained therein half a billion pounds
to get people into work
yes good morning neil i said uh over a
year and a half ago at the beginning of
this crisis that my economic priority
was going to be people's jobs and
today's announcement doubles down on
that a year ago we outlined our plan for
jobs and since then the labor market has
performed incredibly strongly if you
just think back people were expecting
the unemployment rate to reach 12
and thankfully it's less than five
percent it's been falling for months now
more and more people getting into work
record numbers of job vacancies you know
that shows me that our plan for jobs is
working which is why today we're
extending that plan for jobs into next
year to keep supporting people all of
which does suggest though chancellor and
people will be will be very pleased that
there is more money to assist people
getting back into work particularly
those who are perhaps slightly older and
looking for work but doesn't all of this
suggest that with the end of furlough we
will have to expect some pretty
significant rises in unemployment
i said right at the beginning of this
crisis it wasn't going to be possible
for me or quite frankly any chancellor
to save every single person's job but
what i do know is that the interventions
that we put in place have made an
enormous difference as i said at the
beginning of this crisis people thought
the unemployment rate would get to 12
that's millions and millions of people
out of work in fact the unemployment
rate has now been falling for about six
months in a row it's under five percent
we have a lower unemployment rate here
in the uk than america canada france
spain italy amongst others and there are
record numbers of job vacancies so i
think the plan is working now of course
some people are sadly have lost their
job and will lose their job but that's
why i want them to be reassured that we
are throwing literally the kitchen sink
at helping them get a new job new skills
new opportunities and we know that
that's been working over the past 12 to
18 months and that's why we're doing
more of it today
uh clearly as mentioned in the
introduction you are speaking to us from
manchester from the conservative party
conference and one thing i am sure
practically every attendee would wish to
hear from the chancellor and they did
the prime minister is that there won't
be any more tax rises the manifesto
promise has been broken once can you
guarantee that it won't be broken again
well it was a very difficult decision to
put up people's taxes no chancellor
wants to do that certainly no
conservative chancellor difficult for me
difficult for the prime minister but
just remember why we did that that was
to make sure that our nhs could get the
significant resources that it needs to
help recover strongly from coronavirus
i've missed operations i'll just get on
to that and also alongside that to usher
in some reforms to social care that
governments have ducked for decades and
this prime minister deserves enormous
credit for gripping those and
implementing uh some changes there not
least to invest in our social care
workforce to make sure that they get the
recognition that they deserve and those
things are significant investments 12
billion pounds and we need to pay for
those and that's why we took the
difficult but i believe responsible
decision to do what we did
sure but but at the same time we are
hearing from the local government
association that they are going to have
to see council tax rises perhaps as
large coming close to double figures
nine percent to plug the black hole in
in social care i mean can you guarantee
that we won't have to see a rise in
council taxes
well social care is funded by a mix of
different ways one way is through local
taxes like council tax and the adult
social care precept now that's existed
for years that's one part of the funding
system and the other part of can you
guarantee that
and we know this well i wouldn't i
wouldn't i can't i can't yes and later
in the year we have something called the
local government finance settlement neil
where the secretary of state for local
government sets out all the plans for
local government for the coming year it
wouldn't be right for me to preempt that
but but what people should know is we
want to put more money into social care
that's why we took the decisions that we
did there will be as i said these are
landmark reforms to cap the catastrophic
costs that people will be liable for
more investment in the social care
workforce more integration between the
nhs and social care and as i said at the
beginning significant investment in the
nhs to make sure that we recover
strongly and work our way through the
backlogs let's talk supply chain then
just
for a brief second
it has been reported that figures from
the industry met with representatives
from the government back in june
about the risks the issues of the issues
within the supply chain they warned
about potential numbers did that meeting
not take place
or did the government just ignore that
they had been warned that this was all
coming down the pipeline
so i'm not obviously aware of the
particular circumstances of the meeting
that you're describing but what i would
say just to put this in context now of
course we're grappling with some
challenges in supply chains uh that you
that you highlighted as did your report
i think the first thing to say is it's
not just here these things are happening
all around the world because of the way
that economies everywhere are recovering
reasonably rapidly from coronavirus
after a period of of having been closed
down that's causing some adjustment
issues which all of us around the world
are working through and with regard to
hgv drivers you'll know in your report
covered some of the steps that we're
taking to alleviate some of those uh
issues not least increasing the testing
capacity of hgv drivers temporary visas
five thousand of which hundreds are
starting imminently you know those are
the types of things that the government
do to make additions
well i'm not i'm not aware of the
particular meeting you have but it's
also worth bearing in mind that this as
i said there are a shortage of hgv
drivers not just here in the uk but
across europe i think the last data i
saw from uh from an intelligence body
said something hundreds of thousands of
shortages across europe so this is this
is a as i said this is not just an issue
that we are grappling with here it's
broader than that but we are doing and
people should be reassured that we are
doing absolutely everything we can to
mitigate those challenges as best we can
i suppose the question is then but you
know if we got started a little bit
sooner and all of this we might not be
in the situation we're in at the moment
where both you and the prime minister
are not ruling out shortages come
christmas time
well what we are saying is we're
determined to do everything we can and
we are you know whether it's with hev
drivers or more broadly to ease some of
the challenges that we're seeing in
supply chains so speeding up testing
capacity temporary visas these are the
types of things that can make a
practical difference we are committed to
doing all of those and we continue to
engage with the industry in different
sectors to see if there are other things
that we should or could be doing but i
said we're working very hard to mitigate
as much of the challenges here as
possible whilst acknowledging you know
these are not issues that are confined
solely to the uk many country countries
are saying the same thing i mean
as someone else within your party said
not that long ago it does appear that
the government believes that there isn't
there is an upside to these big
supermarket supply chains being broken
up i mean if that's the case what is it
so i didn't quite understand your
question
upside into what sorry neil the upside
into the breakup of the supermarket
supply chains
a breakup of the supply chains
well i don't think anyone would say that
there's an upside to
you know people struggling with supply
chain challenges and not being able to
get what they want at the time they
wanted no one wants to see that i think
what what we have said more broadly is
over time you know one of our desires is
to transition ourselves to a higher wage
high skill more productive economy i
think that is a good thing that's part
of what today's plan for jobs
announcement is about in fact it's
giving people the skills they need to
get well paid jobs now over time that's
that's the type of economy we want to
have which is why people don't want to
just pull as a prime minister we don't
want just to pull the lever on more
unskilled migration now in the short
term that's a pragmatic response to some
of the things we're seeing but longer
term we do want to have people in
well-paid jobs and i think i think
that's probably the point uh whether it
was my colleagues or others have been
trying to make indeed i'm just just on
friday in an interview the prime
minister said this
never mind life expectancy never mind
cancer outcomes
look at wage growth what what does it
say of this prime minister's priorities
that he issues you know concerns about
rises in cancer diagnosis he issues
concerns about you know life expectancy
dropping in favor of wages
no i think that was a
mischaracterization of of what he said
and you started this interview earlier
asking me about tax and and tax rises
you know this is a prime minister and a
government that has taken that difficult
decision on tax precisely because we
want to improve cancer diagnosis and
catch up on all the missed appointments
that people had and just two days ago we
announced i think something like 40 new
community diagnostic hubs across the
united kingdom to do exactly that and
early screening and diagnosis of things
like cancer through mri through
ultrasound because we are committed to
people's health i think we've seen that
over the last year and year and a half
and as this interview started with you
know we're prepared to do some quite
difficult things on the tax side to make
sure the nhs is well-funded and and to
do so that we can do all the things that
you just talked about
just just on taxation though once again
we've seen a fairly significant data
dump of papers this time referred to as
the as the pandora papers pointing out
the president's prime ministers at
billionaires are all taking advantage of
offshore uh tax regimes
leaving that to one side i just want to
ask a very straightforward question have
you ever benefited from an offshore
arrangement
no no i i haven't and i think i've seen
these things overnight as well and it's
always tough for me to comment on them
specifically given uh they've only just
emerged and of course hmrc will look
through those to see if there's
something
we can learn but broadly people should
know that we have a very good track
record on on exactly this type of
activity and tackling it we've led the
world in improving the sharing of
information between tax authorities law
enforcement agencies registers of what
are called beneficial ownership it's
something that we you know we are proud
leaders of here in the uk but as as the
paper showed this is a global phenomenon
there's a global dimension to it we can
do our bit but we require other
countries to cooperate with us as well
and you will
continue to expect us to press on that
indeed and i wonder if i can just again
end on on a slightly personal note
you'll have noticed the advice coming
from the police in london um about how
women should behave telling them that
they should flag down a bus if stopped
by a suspicious police officer i mean
you've got daughters yourself they're
quite young but in a few years time they
will be out of the family home i just
wonder what you make
of that advice being given to your
daughter
well
of course we all should be able to trust
the police but the fact that you're even
asking this question i think
demonstrates to me and to everyone that
there's a problem and we need to address
it and you know you've heard lots of
people talk about some of the specific
things we're doing but it probably
starts with everyone and especially men
acknowledging what a problem this is and
making sure that we recognize that
anxiety as you said i have two young
daughters you know wayne cousins was
roaming around an area where my home in
london outside of downing street is you
know brought this home
we have to recognize what a challenge
this is and and work very hard to
address people's fears